[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Give me
one minute, and I'll
show you how Google Kubernetes
Engine can help you modernize
your existing application.
GKE is an
enterprise-grade platform
for stateful and stateless
containerized apps.
It offers managed
Kubernetes and is
comprised of a high-availability
control plane that Google
manages and operates,
nodes, which hold the pods,
and your connected
Google Cloud Services.
You can interact with it using
kubectl or the cloud console.
GKE increases
developer productivity
with pre-built deployment
templates featuring
portability and integrated tools
to accelerate app development
and deployment cycles.
It simplifies
platform operations
with auto-scale, auto-upgrade,
and auto-repair features.
It is secure by
default, including
data encryption
and vulnerability
scanning of container images.
And it supports integrated
cloud monitoring
with infrastructure,
application,
and Kubernetes-specific views.
GKE can help modernize
your applications,
create a continuous
delivery pipeline,
or migrate your
existing tutor app.
Next time you're thinking about
modernizing your apps quickly,
take a minute to look at
Google Kubernetes Engine.
For more info, check out
cloud.google.com/kubernetes
engine.